辰巳社長です僕はちょっと公がこの企画を助け目たくて
向け今回これをしたくて頑張って確かめましたこんな僕はこの下来たーー
僕今回結婚が僕この企画をしたくて頑張って食べましたこちら
みんな大好き are you choose カードです itunes card
それ何かといいますと
ここでですねいうあんじゃないですか音楽アプリまあ祖母と色々あるんですけどもう
例えばコレですコレ5000って書いてあるんですよ5000円分5,000円分の
アプリとゲームミュージックとは a型がブックを買うことが出来ると言うんですよ
そうめっちゃカッ僕だけじゃないんですけどねこれ
ジェム実は使用済みなんですけど僕とパフォーマンスの itunes かと僕が
頑張って集めてなんとこのような以前のさんがゲットしたんですけどもうやめちゃ
くちゃいます9分
51,0005番観て500円5番で触れ今からですね通り宇宙箱軍人に遊びに来るん
ですけどもそのユーチューバーねー
なんで結構真面目っぽいんですよ結構真面目というかさっき事前に聞いたらやっぱ
スマホのゲームいろいろやってるみたいです zeal link スト車動画とか
たぶんで itunes カードみたいな
血が騒ぐちぐさはグッズやか機嫌
仮定したいアプリで限りさに暴れに限りタイフーン iphone です魔法ゲームし
てる人は itunes card を見たら課金したくなってしまいます
これは病気です今回初めてそう言って今から僕つに来るんですけども
もう水墨画物にして一人で僕ずつにたとってみそのボケのイベ部屋で大量の
itunes card があったりれる
た細い隠されていたでしたら彼はこっそり itunes カーズを使ってしまうのか
こげと実験やってみると思いますよくゴゾ島高い4すぎるから1個ぐらい使っても
大丈夫かなぁけっぽだけならいいでしょそういう感覚で事件は起きてしまう
完全なサード全部僕のある部屋で隠してターゲット一人の辺に置いて話し合えば使わ
ないようなタイプだと思うんですけどやっぱり人間欲に負けちゃ
んで使うのない事を使っちゃうのかちょっと検証してみたいと思います僕なら使います
よ
若くしていきます
配当いう理由で不自然なぐらいにアイゼン使うとまくちだしておきました
これなら多分誘惑に負けると思います間違いないだからきっとこれであれば1万円
くらいならバレない対応率枚くらいならバレないんですよっていう甘い気持ちで使って
しまい多分コットに使うんじゃないかなと思っております
では
やっぱ小山まあキャッツいかにギアが走らない全然か時代が生んとか
ああああどうぞ
ね ran
葉山食べちゃったんだよね f
ちょっと後尾に行ってくるね2世公っていうかなーって
じゃないけれど
はぁ
ええええええ
うーん
ん
voodoo
th
やっぱりあった格好
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
me
teame
car
uh
どんどんはも少ないでしょうかも違う難しいよね3月が1個スキャンして反応するに
塗っても使われてますって出るからそれでじゃあ
スタートしてワロ明け